herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
vor einem Jahr erklärte russlands
Präsident Putin vier besetzte
ukrainische Gebiete zu russischem
Staatsgebiet eine riesige
propaganda-show feierlich wurden in
Moskau Verträge unterzeichnet die
Aufnahme der vier Gebiete der vier
Regionen luhans dann jetzt aborigia und
herson in die Russische Föderation
besiegelt und das ganze gefeiert dabei
waren schon zum damaligen Zeitpunkt
nicht einmal alle vier Gebiete unter
komplett unter russischer Kontrolle nun
jetzt sich diese ich nenne sie mal
pseudoanexion für morgen ist ein großes
Konzert mitten in Moskau mitten auf dem
Roten Platz geplant und voraussichtlich
wird sich der Putin feiern lassen dabei
gibt es eigentlich gar nichts zu feiern
denn anstatt vor zurück und die vier
Gebiete tatsächlich komplett unter
Kontrolle zu bringen sind putinstruppen
eher auf dem Rückmarsch zumindest
definitiv stark in der Defensive ja und
das macht Putin heute er zeigt sich mit
tschetschenenführer kadirov über dessen
Gesundheitszustand tagelang gerätselt
wurde und auch zugeschaltet mehrere pro
russische separatistenführer Putins
versucht Stärke zeigen dabei zeigen
diese Bilder der letzten Tage die
russische Schwäche die ukrainischen
Angriffe auf die Krim auf die russische
Schwarzmeerflotte und auf das russische
Hauptquartier das alles zeigt Putins
Militär ist ordentlich unter Druck
welche Optionen hat Putin noch wie steht
es um seine Truppen wie ist die Lage für
seine Soldaten wir reden heute darüber
mit unserem militär-experten Gustav
gressel und später auch noch mit unserer
ZDF reporterin Anne Brühl in der Ukraine
wenn ihr fragen habt schnell her damit
dann können wir mit beiden darüber reden
zunächst aber einen guten Abend nach
Berlin in unserer Hauptstadtstudio denn
da ist unser Militär Experte Gustav
gressel mit dem wir jetzt die Lage
analysieren wollen erstmal schön guten
Abend und vielen Dank dass Sie mit dabei
sind
vielen herzlichen Dank schönen Abend wie
gesagt welche Optionen hat Putin noch
wenn die Ukraine an allen Ecken und
Fronten eben vorrücken nehmen wir mal
als Beispiel den Süden die ukrainische
Offensive ist zwar langsam aber es ist
doch die Rede vom Durchbruch bei
robotine warum ausgerechnet dort der
Durchbruch der Ukraine und wie steht es
eben da um die Truppen von Wladimir
Putin
ja die russischen Verteidigungslinien
sind unsere enormen Druck äh es wurden
in der Vergangenheit zwei falsche Wege
die Visionen hier in die Schlacht
geworfen die siebte und die 76 beide
sind ausgesprochene Elite Verbände der
russischen Armee also qualitativ sicher
das was man das Beste was man zurzeit
hat aber auch diese Verbände sind
mittlerweile abgekämpft konnten die
Ukraine hat zwar verlangsamen aber nicht
aufhalten
jetzt gibt es Gerüchte dass das ähm
25ste in die Schlacht geworfen wird ein
Verband der sich eigentlich in
Aufstellung
befindet der noch nicht wirklich
einsatzbereit ist aber der jetzt
sozusagen schon
in die Ukraine gehen soll und die
Ukraine verlegt wird damit Russland den
Druck auf die Ukraine wieder erhöhen
kann bzw die die Verteidigung
weiterführen kann das zeigt natürlich
dass man mit den Kräften schon sehr
überstreckt ist gleichwohl das muss man
auch sagen aufgrund der technischen
Neuerungen vor allen Dingen im Bereich
der Drohnen dass ich durch Leute Ring
und nischens wie man das auf Englisch
sagt also durch Drohnen die ins Ziel
stürzen sich dort zerstören entweder wie
die russischen Lernzeit speziell dafür
gebaut oder improvisiert wie viele
umgebaute renn-drohnen kann ich enorme
panzerabwehrkapazität schnell aufbieten
ohne dass ich die Schützen exponieren
müssen ich kann
mechanisierte Spitzen schnell angreifen
das zweite ist sowohl die Russen als
auch die Ukraine verwenden mittlerweile
computergestützte Programme um
Artillerie sehr schnell anzufordern um
die Genauigkeit ihres artillers zu
steigern und vor allen Dingen auch
Drohnen um das Feuer zu korrigieren
damit kann ich Feuerkraft sehr kurz sehr
schnell nur weite Strecken hierbei rufen
an alles das hängt die Offensive alles
das führt dazu dass wir so eine Art
erster Weltkrieg Situation haben wo
truppenmassierungen wo
Überraschungsmoment kaum noch möglich
ist das behindert sowohl die russische
Seite also auch die ukrainische Seite
bei ihren offensivbewegungen deshalb
sehen wir jetzt im Süden ebenso ein
seesrängen wo natürlich die Ukraine
Erfolge haben aber diese Erfolge immer
kleinräumig bleiben ein Kilometer am Tag
500 Meter am Tag deshalb aber jetzt auch
dieser Konzentration der ukrainischen
Kräfte auf den Raum Talk Mark weil hier
die Strecke nach liverpoin hinunter das
heißt die Strecke die man braucht um die
Landverbindungen zur Grimm zu kappen die
kürzeste ist wann weiß dadurch dass die
Russen auch sich so schwer zum Angriff
auch dass man zum Beispiel Flanken
besser schützen kann weil man natürlich
sich in der verteidigen leicht tut und
dass ich hier wenn man die Kräfte
konzentriert man über den Herbst über
den Winter der den Ziel die
lernverbindungen zu kappen
wahrscheinlich am nächsten kommt
jetzt haben wir schon die erste Frage
die ja bei dem was Sie beschrieben haben
auch passt und zwar fragt Eduard Kuhn
über kunt über Youtube sind die
derzeitigen Erfolge taktischer oder
strategischer Natur und wie ist die
Moral der Russen der russischen Truppen
kann man mit Bildern wie im Herbst 22
rechnen
nein der Krieg ist mittlerweile in
sozusagen technisch und er ist auch von
der Art der Einsatzführung so weit von
dem Krieg den wir aus dem letzten Jahr
kennen entfernt aber das ist fast die
Tag und Nacht
gehen wir also um die erste Frage zu
beantworten alle diese Durchbrüche all
diese Folge sind taktische Natur wir
haben noch keinen operativ verwehrbaren
und wir haben noch keine strategisch
verwertbaren Durchbruch und das wirkt
sich natürlich auch auf die
Unterstützung die die Ukraine z.B
fordert also letztes Jahr gab es große
Diskussionen um Leopard und Marder
weil im Grunde der Krieg im letzten Jahr
in etwa denklich was man sich in den
80er Jahren unter einem Konflikt
zwischen zwei Großmächten vorgestellt
hat eine mechanisierten Kampf wo es um
gepanzer der Verbände um natürlich auch
im Artillerie und Kampf der verbundenen
Waffen geht
in etwas so wieder kalte Kriege
aufgehört hat und da gab es sozusagen
die Ukrainer versuchen versucht sein so
zu agieren wie Indikator agiert hätte -
Luftwaffe und die Russen haben sich auf
ihre alten Stärken zurück besonnen
starke Artillerie massierte Angriffe
das funktioniert für beide Seiten nicht
mehr ich möchte hier verweisen auf ein
sehr gutes Interview dass der
ukrainische General bordano der Chef der
Spezialkräfte gegeben hat in dem auch
gesagt hat das funktioniert auf der
russischen Seite funktionieren diese
menschenisierten Durchstoß auch nicht
gerissenhof hat diesen verheerenden
Angriff auf alle da persönlich angeführt
und das ähm
damit leitet sich die Frage ein Bisschen
über zur Moral der Truppe grassimo
besteht auf seinen Doktrin der besteht
auf der schulmässigen auf schulmäßigen
Angriffen das so ein Vertreter der alten
Schule der will dass der Krieg so
geführt wird wie eben in den 80er Jahren
es funktioniert auch russische Seite
nicht irgendwo da gab es hochende
russische Verluste und wenn ukrainische
Generäle mit ihnen amerikanischen
gegenüber streiten wie diese Offensive
und wie schnell diese Offensive
angetragen werden soll und wie stark man
sich exponieren soll und wie stark man
sich massieren soll dann spielt sich
dort genau dasselbe Streit wieder ab wo
eben Generäle die nicht in diesem Krieg
sitzen sehr weit ab der Front sitzen und
mit der Washington Post reden eine
andere Vorstellung von Krieg haben wir
jetzt in der Ukraine sich darstellt da
ist der Vorteil auf der ukrainischen
Seite weil wie gesagt auf der
ukrainischen Seite von den einzelnen
Soldaten ein bisschen offen die
Armeeführung im Grunde das verstanden
wird auf der russischen Seite und das
haben wir in den ganzen Episoden und
bregorien um die Abberufung von
generalbau auf etc gesehen die in der
auf der russischen Seite gibt es einen
Splitt zwischen der Armeeführung dem
Generalstab dem Verteidigungsministerium
und der mir die in der Ukraine selber
eingesetzt ist und wie sieht dass es so
wie sich die Führung das vorstellt nicht
funktioniert
und deshalb auch ständig diese
Streitereien und deshalb kommen diese
Streitereien dann auch über müllblocker
oder über andere Personen zum Vorschein
das heißt das Verteidigungsministerium
kapiert gar nicht was los ist es Plan
falsch das hat die falsche Logistik
gesetzt die falschen Prioritäten
nichtsdestotrotz natürlich russland hat
noch Ressourcen und Russland auf
Kriegswirtschaft umgestellt russland
versucht durch Masse die Ukraine immer
noch zu erdrücken in dem Sinn ist es für
Putin nicht so wichtig ob man auch von
einer guten oder von einer schlechteren
Linie versucht die Ukraine langfristig
zu drucken es ist eine langfristige
abnutzungsstrategie und einen
langfristiges erdrücken in der Ukraine
ob die Ukraine und Video Ukraine es
schafft sich dem zu entziehen hängt
natürlich wieder in erster Linie von
ihren westlichen Unterstützern ab denn
zum gegenwärtigen Zeitpunkt werden 85%
aller militärischen Verbrauchsgüter vom
Panzer bis zur Munition außerhalb der
Ukraine produziert bzw bereitgestellt
und es liegt am besten sich auch jetzt
intellektuell darauf ein einzustellen
dass dieser Krieg eben sich gewandelt
hat dass das Kriegsbild ein anderes ist
dass die Ukraine anders geschichtete
Unterstützung zum Teil braucht und dass
wir auch in dem Training dass wir den
ukrainischen Soldaten geben mit bedenken
müssen dass die alten Rezepte aus den
80er Jahren nicht mehr in dem Sinn
funktionieren wie wir es gedacht haben
sie haben gerade sehr schön beschrieben
auf russischer Seite Streit auch bei der
Führung unterschiedliche Einschätzungen
eine Frage von einem User weshalb nimmt
die Frustration in der russischen Armee
weiter zu ist es so dass den einfachen
Soldaten eben an der Front eben genau
das funktioniert wenn er den Eindruck
hat die da oben die Führung streitet und
wir werden einfach als Kanonenfutter an
die Front geschickt und weil die
einfachen Soldaten sehen dass das was
sich sozusagen
nicht erfüllbar ist und dass sie
natürlich sehen dass Forderungen nicht
erfüllbar sind das Forderungen selbst
wenn man Befehle ausführt dass sie zu
enormen Kosten kommen und das klingt
natürlich die einfachen Soldaten auch
mit das die die befohlenen Angriffe zum
Großteil aussichtslos sind dass sie aber
trotzdem durchgeführt werden weil sie
befohlen wurden und das ist natürlich
kein kein schöner Anblick wenn man auf
der anderen Seite auf der ukrainische
Seite in einen Angriff geht er natürlich
auch blutig ist und die Ukraine
haben auch große Verluste aber einen
General im Hintergrund hat der im
Fernsehen und öffentlich verkündigt wir
führen diesen Krieg so Personal schonend
wie möglich und wir versuchen jeden
einzelnen Toten ukrainischen Soldaten zu
vermeiden dann ist das natürlich was
anderes im Hinterkopf wenn der nicht
Schlacht geht und sagt okay es muss
jetzt halt sein aber er hat zumindest
das Vertrauen dass seine Führung ihn
nicht unnötig verheizt und das seine
Kommandeure und seine Nachbarn und die
Truppen auf die er Zusammenarbeit
angewiesen ist schauen dass er sein
Leben und das Leben seiner Kameraden so
so wertvoll wie möglich ist und nicht
umsonst geopfert wird das ist ein Norma
moralischer Unterschied der natürlich
dann auch im Kampf die einzelnen
Soldaten besser und entscheiden er
kämpfen lässt weil natürlich niemand
weder die Russen noch die Ukraine
sterben besonders gerne
sie haben es beschrieben es ist auf
beiden Seiten schwierig ein
abnutzungskrieg keine schnellen Erfolge
eine schwierige Lage eben auch Büsche
Armee ein Jahr nach dieser ich sag mal
pseudoanexion ist sie in der Defensive
und die Frage ist natürlich auch ein
bisschen wie geht es denn eigentlich den
Menschen in den annektierten in
Anführungsstrichen völkerrechtlich
annektierten Gebieten in den russischen
besetzten Gebieten da kann man nicht
einfach mal als korresponden von Moskau
aus hinfahren das ist äußerst schwierig
dort Objektive Berichte Bilder zu
bekommen aber unsere Reporterin an der
Brühl die in der Ukraine ist in Harke
sie hat es zumindest geschafft mit
Menschen zu sprechen die ihr beschrieben
haben was sie unter russischer Besatzung
erleben eine was hast du von diesen
Menschen gehört und auch wie schwierig
ist es erstmal an diese Berichte zu
kommen
ja auch von hier aus ist es schwierig
auch wir kommen ja nicht in diese
besetzten Gebiete dazu müssten wir die
Frontlinie überqueren aber wir hören
natürlich auch immer Schilderungen davon
wie russische Pässe unter Zwang
ausgegeben werden wie Menschen gefoltert
werden im August hatte ich die
Möglichkeit mit meinem Team in der
Region Sumi unweit von hier an einem
Grenzpunkt zu drehen da ist diese Grenze
zwischen Russland und der Ukraine
tatsächlich
durchlässig für Flüchtlinge aus diesen
besetzten Gebieten wir haben zusammen
mit Helfern Menschen in Empfang genommen
eine junge Frau zum Beispiel die mit
zwei kleinen Kindern aus der Hassan kam
die hatte eine unendliche Odyssee hinter
sich tagelang über russisches Gebiet
immer in der Sorge eben doch nicht
durchgelassen zu werden die war
unendlich glücklich dann wieder in der
Ukraine zu sein wir haben eine Frau aus
melittopol getroffen die gesagt hatte
ohne russischen passe wird man im
Krankenhaus nicht mehr behandelt auch
nicht bei farbfällen ohne russischen
Pass darf kein Kind in melittopol zur
Schule gehen sie hat auch gesagt die
russische Erzählung in diesen besetzten
Gebieten ist natürlich eine andere die
auch durch die Medien verbreitet wird
aber sie sagte mir wenn man das dann
sieht was diese russischen Medien
verbreiten und wenn man die Situation in
melittopol sieht dann passt das
überhaupt nicht aufeinander das ist Lüge
Propaganda hat sie gesagt wir haben dort
gelebt wir wissen wie es dort ist
jetzt gibt es ja Gebete die von den
Ukrainern zurückerobert worden sind die
also russisch besetzt waren die aber in
der Zwischenzeit befreit worden sind und
du warst in Issum was haben wir die
Menschen da eben direkt dann berichten
können
war eine Stadt die gleiche zu Beginn des
Kriegs von den Russen erobert wurde das
ist hier in der Region und die gut sechs
Monate lang eben unter russischer
Besatzung gelebt haben Visionen andere
Städte kopianske die wurden damals in
dieser herbstoffensive ziemlich genau
vor einem Jahr befreit in die Zoom hat
man dieses Massengrab im Kiefernwald
gefunden die Bilder die sind damals um
die Welt gegangen und wir waren heute in
diesem Kiefernwald wo
449 Leichen verscharrt wurden während
dieser Besatzung so muss man das sagen
die ukrainischen Behörden haben diese
Leichen inzwischen exhumiert die
Staatsanwaltschaften hier nach Harke
ermittelt dokumentiert man hatte da
Leichen mit gefesselten Händen gefunden
mehrere Leichen in einem Grab ähm
Leichen bei denen oft offensichtlich war
dass sie durch Gewalt Anwendung zu Tode
gekommen sind und für die Menschen in
die Missionen in der Ukraine insgesamt
sind diese Ermittlungen und diese
Dokumentierung unendlich wichtige weil
sie nämlich hoffen dass irgendwann
einmal die Täter auch zur Rechenschaft
gezogen werden und weil für sie
natürlich auch wichtig ist überhaupt
Gewissheit zu haben was mit ihren
Angehörigen ihren Freunden passiert ist
und ihnen eine angemessene letzte
Ruhestätte zu geben
jetzt heute in Kiew hat sich
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg
überraschend mit Präsident selensky
getroffen es ist nicht verwunderlich es
ging eben auch wieder um das Thema
Waffen Waffen die die Ukraine braucht
eine was sagen dir die Ukrainer die
Menschen ganz einfach wenn es eben um
das Thema Waffenlieferungen und vor
allen Dingen das lange Warten auf Waffen
von unten geht
die Namen dieser ausländischen
Waffensysteme die gehen den Ukrainern
hier wirklich sehr flüssig über die
Lippen wenn wir beim Drehen unterwegs
sind die Menschen hören dass wir aus
Deutschland kommen dann sagen sie oft
wie gut dass sie die Leoparden geschickt
habe jetzt warten wir auf Taurus und wir
warten da ganze dringlich drauf und
dieses Warten ist etwas was die Menschen
hier natürlich auch ein bisschen müde
macht Beispiel Apps da kam die Zusage
der Amerikaner für diese Kampfpanzer im
März die ersten sind in dieser Woche
hier in der Ukraine eingetroffen das hat
natürlich auch damit zu tun dass er
ukrainische Soldaten auf diese
westlichen Waffensysteme geschult werden
müssen und das passiert ja auch überall
und trotzdem ist die Ungeduld der der
Ukrainer natürlich groß denn
gleichzeitig geht dieser Krieg ja weiter
und er wird eben nicht nur an der Front
geführt sondern die Russen greifen ja
massiv in den letzten Wochen Städte im
ganzen Land an und hier in
gibt es eigentlich täglich Luftalarm
viele Menschen verbringen die Nächte im
Flur ihrer Wohnungen oder gleich im
Bunker und natürlich ist da eine
Ungeduld da ein hoffen auf mehr Waffen
zum Beispiel zur Luftverteidigung zum
Beispiel um russischen Nachschub zu
unterbinden weil man so auf mehr
Sicherheit hier im ganzen Land für die
Zivilbevölkerung hofft
Anne dann ganz herzlichen Dank für diese
Schilderungen und wir wollen über das
was die Menschen dir jetzt erzählt haben
eben weiter reden mit Gustav
Politikwissenschaftler und
Militärexperte vom European Council der
uns aus Berlin zugeschaltet ist Herr
gresse anna hat es gesagt Abrahams
Panzer sind geliefert worden das ist
gefeiert worden aber es ist im März
gefeiert worden das Versprechen sie zu
liefern da sind Monate vergangen
wiederholt sich das ganze jetzt mit
anderen Dingen auch mit den Taurus Marc
Flughafen
ja mit dem Taurus muss man den
Bundeskanzler fragen da bin ich ehrlich
gesagt überfragt wie lange es jetzt
gehen wird oder gehen soll fakt ist die
Ukraine braucht fernkampfmittel um die
Nachschubwege über die Krim anzugreifen
hier sind die Wege länger die Straßen
länger das die Russen haben sich darauf
eingestellt in der Reichweite von
heimatraketen keine großen
Umschlagplätze für Munition zu
unterhalten keine Truppenkonzentrationen
die gerade im Süden gibt es ja wenig gut
belastbare
Eisenbahnverbindungen wenig große
Straßen das heißt im Grunde kann man die
Verkehrsinfrastruktur und die Logistik
die sich an dieser Verkehrsinfrastruktur
anhängt ja gut angreifen und dann was
ist das zweite schwieriger weil der
damals sehr Schwerindustrie Region
natürlich ein viel dichteres Netz an
Eisenbahnlinien und viel dichteres Netz
an gut ausgebauten Straßen mit
tragfähigen Brücken aufweist als die
silok mal die hauptsächlich eine
landwirtschaftliche Region ist aber es
gibt natürlich wenige Staaten die hier
fernkampfmittel also
Raketen mit einer Reichweite von von 100
km und größer zugesagt haben die Briten
und Franzosen die Briten liefern seit
März ihre Storm shadows und die
Franzosen
liefern seit dem Sommer ihre Skype
marschflowkörpern die Amerikaner haben
jetzt frisch zugesagt die
atacamsische beziehungsweise quasi
ballistische Rakete die etwa 300 Meter
weit 300 km weit schießt die nach je
nach Variante und und Sprengstoff
da ist natürlich jedes andere System
auch willkommen unter anderem natürlich
auch der Taurus weil gerade bei den
Franzosen und breiten die sind ja im
vereinigungsbudget ähnlich gestreckt wie
das bei der Bundeswehr war man soll da
nicht glauben dass es anderen
europäischen Armeen immer so viel besser
ging und dass die im Schlaraffenland
Leben das sind natürlich auch diese
Waffensysteme nicht sehr zahlreich
vorhanden und weder Großbritannien nach
Frankreich kann sozusagen ein gesamten
Bestand an diesen Waffensystemen abgeben
deshalb natürlich
wendet sich die Ukraine alle
europäischen oder westlichen Staaten die
auch solche Mittel haben ob man diesen
Kampf um den Nachschub nicht
unterstützen kann man muss ja auch
bedenken wenn zum Beispiel sehr
erfolgreich mit diesen Skype oder
stormscheider Raketen ein Munitionsdepot
angegriffen wird dann wird viel Munition
vernichtet dann steht die Artillerie
oder hat die Artillerie in einem
gewissen frontsektor eine Zeit lang
Probleme mit dem Munitionsnachschub aber
natürlich wie irgendwo anders ein das
nächste Munitionslager richte bzw die
munitionszüge die auch Russland kommen
die werden dann an einem anderen Bahnhof
oder woanders umgeschlagen und von dort
wird mit LKW weiter verteilt
und das ist sozusagen dann wie ein
makerball spielen man muss ständig
irgendwo hin schlagen und deshalb
braucht die Ukraine sozusagen eine
munitionszufluss über die Zeit und der
lässt sich natürlich umso leichter
bewerkstelligen umso mehr starten hier
mitmachen jetzt haben sie ja viele
Waffensysteme genannt sie haben auch
gesagt es muss ein munitionszufluss sein
es braucht Raketen die eben weiter
reichen um eben weit entfernte
Versorgungswege der Russen zu treffen
Rachel oder Rachel Amber schreibt mich
würde interessieren welche Waffen jetzt
ein Game changer wären das haben wir
über Taurus gesprochen ist es einfach
die Gesamtlieferung nahtlos an Waffen
eben kommt oder was ist ganz besonders
wichtig also ein ein einzelnes
Waffensystem ist nie entgehen changer
selbst die Storm Shadow und Skype
Muskelkörper die enorm wichtig sind für
die Ukraine und die jetzt sehr
spektakuläre Treffer gelandet haben also
ich habe mir vorhin das Video gesehen
von dem Hauptquartier der russischen
Schwarzmeerflotte wo man sogar im Video
sieht wie eine entweder Skype oder Storm
Shadow die schauen von außen gleich auf
gleich aus im Sturzflug auf dieses
Hauptquartier hinunterfällt und und dann
drinnen betoniert aber diese diese
Angriff wurde ja sehr genau vorbereitet
angefangen von
Spezialkräften die
Bohrplattformen im Schwarzen Meer
unterbesitz nehmen und dort früh waren
gerade der Russen und elektronische
abhörstationen abnehmen damit die Russen
eben nicht beobachten können oder nicht
messen können was die Ukraine an ihrer
schwarz mehr Küste machen dann gab
spezialoperationen die mit
infantastischen Kräften Flieger
Abwehrstellungen und Radargeräte
angegriffen haben dann gab es das
Anwerben von Informanten wann sich wo
welcher general trifft in den russischen
Streitkräften doch Widerstandskämpfer
durch Partisanen Aufklärung der
Bewegungen der russischen Flieger der
Kräfte durch Partisanen und durch
fernspieler dann gab es kombinierte
Drohnen und marschflugkörperangriffe
wieder gegen Fliegerabwehr und
radarstellungen der Russen auf basierend
auf diesen Daten wo man Drohnen zum Teil
eingesetzt hat als sozusagen Köder um
die Russen zum aufschalten ihrer
Radargeräte zu zwingen und dann sind sie
dann angegriffen hatten alles das im
Vorfeld damit ich sozusagen durchkommen
mit diesen mit diesen Waffensystemen zum
Hauptquartier der Schwarzmeerflotte und
zu den trockentalks die so wichtig sind
für die Reparatur der Kriegsschiffe der
Schwarzmeer Flotte das heißt allein das
zeigt das ist natürlich diesen
spektakulären Einsatz dieser
hochtechnikierten Waffensystem eine
Vielzahl von kleineren Operationen
vorangegangen ist wo von Spezialkräfte
Soldat mit einem Sturmgewehr bis zum
Kampf Taucher bis zu Drohnen eine
Vielzahl von anderen Waffensystemen
gebraucht wurden damit dieser eine
Angriff oder diese zwei Angriffe auf das
Hauptquartieren auf das trockentalk
Sitzen und passen und so ist es mit
jeder anderen landoperation der Leopard
ist ein ganz wichtiges Element jetzt
auch in der Gegenoffensive aber
natürlich kann er nur funktionieren wenn
es auch mechanisierte Infanterie gibt
wenn es pionierkräfte gibt die
Minenräumen die Artillerie ist enorm
wichtig die elektronische Kampfführung
ist enorm wichtig
die drohnenkräfte die den Leopards
einweisen wo sie angreifen können wo sie
Ziele haben die sie vorwarnen wenn
andere Ziele auftauchen bzw
panzerabwehrkräfte verlegt werden all
das ist ein Zusammenspiel und nur dieses
Zusammenspiel
bringt eben Erfolg auf dem Schlachtfeld
und nie ein einzelnes Waffensystem
deshalb ist ja auch in der ganzen
militärischen Unterstützung das eine
sind die Waffensysteme das zweite ist
Logistik Material Erhaltung
Instandsetzung und dann auch ganz
wichtig und da freut es mich ja auch
dass Deutschland hier gerade in letzter
Zeit die Norm vieles geleistet hat das
ist Ausbildung und Training auch vor
allen Dingen Training von Kommandanten
von kommandieren damit man planen kann
damit die Kräfte gut geführt werden das
ist enorm wichtig
der hervorragend beschrieben Herr
gressel wie ja man lange sich Gedanken
macht eben wie ein Angriff auf die Krim
aussieht die Ukraine schafft es
mittlerweile eben auch einige Schiffe
mit Getreide sicher über das Schwarze
Meer zu bekommen weil sie wohl auch die
russische Schwarzmeerflotte so unter
Druck setzt jetzt kommt ein bisschen mal
die strategiefrage Action Jackson
schreibt fragt über Youtube könnte Putin
die Grimm als Trumpf für Verhandlungen
nutzen um eine strategische Kapitulation
abzuwenden bleiben einfach mal bei dem
Grillen bei der Krim welche Rolle spielt
die grim den sie haben ja auch sehr
schön beschrieben wie die Ziele der
Ukraine sind Richtung also auf das Meer
vorzustoßen die Grimm abzuschneiden etc
also welche Schlüsselrolle greift die
Frage auf Spiel den Grimm
ja die Grimm spielt in der ukrainischen
Strategie eine eine Schlüsselrolle wir
haben ja vorhin besprochen es ist enorm
mühsam anzugreifen es ist sehr schwierig
vorwärts zu kommen man kommt eine sehr
kleinen Räume vor das heißt die Ukraine
kann zumindest wie es gegenwärtig
aussieht und mit der kann sie nicht
damit rechnen dass jeden
Quadratzentimeter ihres Territoriums mit
offensiv-operationen quasi befreit
sondern man muss schauen wie man das das
verkürzt und hier ist die Idee die
folgende dass man die Creme erstens mal
den Landweg abschneidet auf die Creme
das zweite ist dass man dann eben mit
Fernwaffen also mit Taurus mit Skalp etc
mit betonen mit Dingen die die Ukraine
auch selbst entwickelt die
Versorgungspunkte auf der Creme angreift
das heißt die Grimm Brücke die Häfen in
denen die Fähren anlegen die Umschlag
Punkte
für Versorgungsgüter und so das Halten
der Krim für Russland logistisch und
tragbar zu machen und das weiß man
natürlich auf der ukrainischen Seite
auch mit der Krim hat er nicht nur die
russische Aggression gegen die Ukraine
begonnen 2014 märz 2014 sondern sie ist
ja auch für Putin das wichtigste Element
seiner seine Eroberungen ohne die Krim
ist sozusagen der Rest der Ukraine quasi
wertlos das heißt wenn Putin vor der
Situation steht dass Sie die Creme
verlieren könnte dann
ist er zumindest aus der ukrainischen
Sicht
bereit auf den Verhandlungstisch zu
gehen und dann könnt ihr eben auch
bereit sein auf diesem Verhandlungstisch
Gebiete abzugeben die die Ukraine noch
nicht
zurückerobert bzw befreit hat und
deshalb konzentriert sich jetzt die
ukrainische Gegenoffensive ebenso stark
auf das asow Chemie so stark auf die
Verbindungslinien zu Grimm und deshalb
bereitet man diese ganzen Schläge gegen
die
Krim vor deshalb die
Vorbereitung eben dieser dieser Schläge
durch die Montage bzw Schädigung der
russischen Fliegerabwehr damit man hier
Handlungsfreiheit gewinnt die
Schwarzmeerflotte von der Krim hinunter
drängen hinaus drängen damit sie nicht
mehr aus der Krim heraus operieren kann
die Krim nicht mehr schützen kann die
Angriffe gegen
Luftwaffenstützpunkte der Russen oben
kam Flugzeuge rauszudrängen wenn sie auf
der Creme sind werden sie beschädigt
angegriffen sie müssen sich zurückziehen
das heißt sie haben wieder eine längere
Zeit um den Einsatzraum zu fliegen
Russen haben sehr wenig luftgetankungs-
richtig negativ auf sie auf und das
alles wirkt sich negativ auf die
Möglichkeit aus die Creme effektiv zu
schützen und die die ukrainische
Strategie geht eben davon aus dass wenn
ich wenn ich die Creme zur Disposition
Stelle militärisch dann muss posine
reden dann kann er sich den nicht mehr
entziehen also eine spannende Sache wenn
man diesen Hintergrund diesen
strategischen einfach mal sieht kommen
wir zu ja faktischen Zahlen Nikola
Michael Spalt schreibt über Youtube wie
schätzen Sie Herr gressel denn das
aktuelle Verhältnis der Verlustzahlen
der beiden Seiten ein die hat sich das
Verhältnis zweite Frage auch bei der
Stärke der Artillerie mittlerweile
verändert
also zu den
Verlustzahlen muss ich ehrlich sagen
kenne ich keine vernünftige belastbare
Größe aber es gab da unlängst einen
Artikel in der New York Times der den
Ukraine 70.000 Tote und etwa 120.000
verwundete
unterstellt ich muss ehrlich sagen ich
glaube das nicht das würde ein
kompletten Zusammenbruch des
ukrainischen Militärs Sanitätswesens
bedeuten wenn der Anteil von Toten zu
schwer verwundeten zu hoch ist
ich glaube hier die New York Times Daten
aus bachmut bekommen
im bachmut in den letzten vor allen
Dingen in den letzten Monaten der
ukrainischen Verteidigung waren die
Wege über die verwundete evakuiert haben
werden müssen sehr prekäraus
ukrainischer Sicht und es hat lange
gedauert bis man die Verwundeten
rausbekommen hat und durch diese lange
dauert sind leider sehr viele schwer
verwundete gestorben wenn ich dieses
Verhältnis dann hochrechne auf den
ganzen Krieg komme ich auf eine viel zu
Höhe hohe Zahl an Toten und eine viel zu
hohe Zahl und ein viel zu hohes
Verhältnis von Toten zu Verwundeten
120.000 schwer Verwundete und Tote wird
wahrscheinlich stimmen aber der Anzahl
der Toten ist weit geringer als 70.000
aber das sind alles Schätzungen
belastbar ist nicht auf der russischen
Seite
wahrscheinlich so knapp unter 300.000
bzw 300.000 schwer verwunderte und tote
der Anteil der Toten ist hier
wahrscheinlich höher
sinnvollere zahlen wobei wie gesagt das
Problem ist wir haben hier überhaupt
keine guten Schätzungen
geht hier hat hier
kommt Russland langsam in Probleme und
zwar in größere Probleme als etwa bei
der mechanisierten Infanterie und bei
der Panzerwaffe das eine ist das
verschießen von Rohren ein Artillerie
Rohr je nachdem was wir brauchen das ist
muss zwischen nach sollte eigentlich
nach drei bis 5000 Schuss in die Wartung
gehen
die Lebensdauer dieser Rohre sind bei
den sowohl auf der ukrainischen Seite
also bei der russischen Seite meistens
weit überzogen aber das Problem auf der
russischen Seite es während die Ukraine
ihre Rohre vor allen Dingen für die
westlichen artilleriesysteme im Westen
nach beschaffen können und wechseln
können sind die Produktionsstraßen für
viele ältere sowjetischer als eine
riesysteme auch in Russland nicht mehr
vorhanden weil dieses Systeme nicht mehr
produziert werden und die Rohr Seelen
also der Innenbau dieser Rohre sind
nicht mehr Verfügbar wir sehen in
russischen Depots das äh die Rohre an
alten Artilleriegeschützen abmontiert
werden um sie als Ersatzteilspender zu
verwenden aber das Problem ist das geht
nur bei einigen wenigen Systemen bei
anderen ist auch der Depotstand schon
längst aufgebraucht das zweite ist die
munitionsproduktion russland hat im
letzten Jahr zwischen 11 und 12
Millionen Schuss arteriemunition
verschossen
in diesem Jahr geht man davon aus dass
sie etwa etwas sieben Millionen
verschießen werden das Problem ist jetzt
ist man mit dem eigenen Lagerkapazitäten
durch und man produziert nur etwa
2,5 Millionen Schuss pro Jahr
etwa etwas über eine Million kann etwa
aus dem Iran kommen aber dann sind Bären
auch die iranischen
Produktionskapazitäten an der Grenze und
Putin trifft sich mit Kindern und weil
Nordkorea auch noch auf großen Munition
beständig sind wir kennen aber die
Größenordnungen die aus Nordkorea sind
nicht das Problem und der gegenwärtige
der gegenwärtige russische
artillerieverbrauch deutet darauf hin
dass ich die Russen in etwa darauf
einstellen pro Jahr so um die drei
Millionen Schuss verbrauchen zu können
was im Vergleich zu den vergangenen
Jahren im Vergleich zu dem was Sie aus
Ihrer Doktrin heraus gewohnt sind zu
verschießen in Norwegen ist
auf der ukrainischen Seite verbessert
sich die munitionslage wenn man von den
ursprünglichen etwa 1,8 1,5 Millionen
Schutz pro Jahr durch die Steigerung vor
allen Dingen in der europäischen
munitionsproduktion langsam hinaufkommt
das heißt die Ukraine verschießen
derzeit etwa gleich viel Munition wie
die Russen pro Tag
zwischen 5 und 8.000 Schuss die
Perspektive auf der ukrainischen Seite
geht aber Richtung Wachstum während auf
der russischen Seite ist weniger wird
zum Schluss noch mal zu verschiedenen
Bildern die wir gesehen haben und
bringen Sie einfach mal zusammen Herr
Gresser sie haben ja beschrieben welche
Rolle auf einmal die Drohnen spielen
Hightech Waffen die es vor langer Zeit
noch gar nicht so gegeben hat die Russen
haben jetzt die landzeit 3 Drohne im
Einsatz wir haben Bilder gesehen einen
Angriff auf einen ukrainischen Flughafen
wo eine ukrainische Miete getroffen wird
mutmaßlich muss man dazu sagen ist es
wohl eine Lenze 3 Drohne die hier
erfolgreich einen ukrainischen Kampf ein
ukrainisches Kampfflugzeug zerstört
gleichzeitig haben wir die Bilder
gesehen die Nato-Generalsekretär
Stoltenberg in der Ukraine in Kiew ist
sich mit selenski trifft was kann denn
der Westen den Ukrainern bieten wenn die
Russen jetzt eine neue Drohne haben die
so weit fliegen kann die so effektiv ist
möglicherweise mutmaßlich
ja das war höchstwahrscheinlich eine
Lenze 3 und wir sehen tagtäglich dass
diese Drohnen sehr effektiv sind es ist
heute
Nato-Generalsekretär in Kiews war
orthopädische und der französische
verteilungsminister in Kiew ein großer
Diskussionspunkt wird natürlich die
pflegeabwehr sein wir gehen in den
nächsten Winter und russische Angriffe
auf ukrainische Energieinfrastruktur
nehmen wir zu das zweite ist aber es
gibt in der NATO es gibt auch in der EU
mittlerweile Geld dafür die nicht nur
Entwicklung sondern auch Forschung eben
auf dem Bereich der Drohnen wir haben in
der Ukraine gesehen wie nur wichtig
dieser Bereich ist und zwar sowohl der
Drohnen also im Einsatz selber also der
Drohnen Abwehr rennen wir uns an die
gegen Offensive infood wir haben schon
gesehen Lithium befreit wurde
bei dieser Gegend Offensive da lief mir
eine Handvoll gepaart mit und diese
Gepard Panzer konnten Flieger per panz
konnten die wenigen russischen Drohnen
die eingesetzt wurden um die ukrainische
Offensive aufzuklären
abschießen und damit den Russen
verwehren die Aufklärung wo das
ukrainische Schwergewicht ist mit
welchen Kräften die Ukraine wo stehen
und somit konnten sich die Russen auf
diese Offensive nicht vorbereiten oder
nicht genügend vorbereiten und hatten
wirkliche Schwierigkeiten sie abzufangen
das Problem ist nachdem die Russen so
viele Drohnen mittlerweile auch
qualitativ viel bessere Drohnen
einsetzen als sie das noch zu Beginn des
Krieges getan haben
sich verbessert haben die
Aufklärungsergebnisse dieser Drohnen in
ihre Kampfführung einzubauen als wohl
was die Artillerie Leitung angeht als
auch was das kann man hier von Kräften
vor Ort angeht das das alles hat dazu
geführt dass eben die ukrainischen
offensiven kleinräumiger werden und
nicht mehr diesen Überraschungsmoment
und nicht mehr diese Handlungsfreiheit
haben eine offensive sozusagen
bei uns in der NATO aber denn unsere die
Bundeswehr jede jeder
Armee innerhalb der NATO die sich jetzt
rückbesinnt auf Landes- und
bündnisverteidigung geht natürlich auch
trainiere auch wieder da zurück wo man
aufgehört hat mit
landungsbündnisverteidigung in den 80er
früh 90er Jahren und das Problem ist
durch dieses taktische Element Drohnen
und elektronische Kampfführung
funktionieren diese alten Rezepte
natürlich nicht nur für die Ukraine
nicht mehr so wie sie sein sollten
sondern auch für uns das heißt natürlich
hat die NATO auch ein Interesse zu
lernen von den Ukrainern welche
Schwierigkeiten haben sie wie können Sie
das lösen wie kann man taktisch die
Probleme lösen die sich hier stellen
aber wie kann man natürlich auch
technisch die Probleme lösen welche
Drohnen Abwehrmittel funktionieren
welche funktionieren nicht
all das gilt es auch für uns zu klären
dementsprechend natürlich erstens die
Unterstützung für die Ukraine zu
verbessern aber auch in unserer
Rüstungsindustrie ein Feedback zu geben
unsere militärischen Planung ein
Feedback zu geben auf was müssen wir
aufpassen
was sind die Trends die sich
bewahrheitet haben was funktioniert
absolut nicht wie müssen wir uns
taktisch weiterentwickeln damit wir eben
nicht in sozusagen in einem möglichen
Verteidigungsfall Kräfte haben die einer
solchen Situation nicht gewachsen sind
denn eines steht fest die russische
Armee lernt aus diesem Krieg und die
russische Armee hat ihre ursprünglichen
Kriegsziele wieder gegen Ukraine
aufgegeben noch hat sie aufgegeben den
Westen als fein zu sehen also das heißt
wir müssen uns darauf einstellen dass
diese Armee die aus diesem Krieg lernt
weiterhin eine Bedrohung für die NATO
darstellen wird und wir müssen jetzt mit
der Ukraine mit lernen wie man den
begegnet
dann gibt es eigentlich keinen
passenderes Schlusswort und vielen
vielen Dank schon mal nach Berlin lieber
Herr gressel für diese Einordnung wir
haben eine ganze Menge gelernt als nur
dass sie eingeordnet haben die
Schlüsselfunktion der Krim dass der
Westen von diesem Krieg lernt Russland
allerdings während dieses Krieges eben
auch eine ganze Menge lernt welche Rolle
auf einmal neuartige Waffen Drohnen
spielen und welche alten Lehrbücher
sozusagen weggeworfen werden können auf
jeden Fall sind morgen in Moskau
Feierlichkeiten ein großes Konzert auf
dem Roten Platz angesagt obwohl es
eigentlich das haben sie auch deutlich
gemacht dort nicht viel zu feiern gibt
die angebliche Annexion oder die
völkerrechtswillige Annektion eine
dieses große Propaganda Sache vor einem
Jahr was jetzt gefeiert wird aber
offenbar für Putin eine Option in diesen
abnutzungskrieg weiterhin Stärke seinem
Volk vorzukaufen
vielen vielen Dank dass Sie dabei waren
für die Einschätzungen Informationen
vielen dank Grüße nach Berlin und ich
danke auch ganz herzlich für Euer
Interesse die vielen Fragen die wir alle
hoffentlich abgearbeitet haben und mit
Herrn Dressel zusammen und an der Bull
beantwortet haben vielen Dank für das
Interesse tschüss und auf Wiedersehen